im heutigen video habe ich was cooles
vor einer stimme los und zwar hat elli
die schwester von meiner freundin
mysteriöse süßigkeiten sachen aus japan
bekommen die heißen poppen gucken und
ich hab selbst noch nie so was gemacht
aber davon erzählt bekommen und zwar
befindet sich darin irgendwelche
schüssel und pulver das muss man einfach
nur mit wasser anrühren und dann wird
aus dem pulver zum beispiel hamburger
cola ketchup also alles aus pulver und
angeblich wird aus dieser packung dieser
gesamte chor und ja darum geht das
heutige video also die elliott das
freundlicherweise zur verfügung gestellt
dass wir das austesten können und ich
bin skeptisch aber ich bin auch sehr
gespannt ist sowie lesen erstmal hier
die anleitung hier steht nach hinten h4
zu ihm
die konkurrenz war leider nicht so
lustig wie ich mir vorgestellt habe mich
lange probiert es einfach aus so leute
wir setzen jetzt hier am tisch und haben
diese verpackung gab es hier auch machen
jetzt öffnen wir das ganze mal wild aus
überhaupt nicht schlau werden einfach
irgendwelche total mysteriösen
schriftzeichen darauf all das hier war
ursprünglich die verpackung und daraus
schneidet man jetzt die schachtel in der
dann später das essen rein gelegt wird
[Musik]
du meinst dass es also die cola zb die
echte cola schmeckt noch schmeckt oder
die richtige echte cola und geht raus zu
erleichtern und eine sache hier das an
den seiten sind einfach so aus dieser
frittiertes huhn oder chicken nuggets
oder sowas und ich bin extrem gespannt
aber ich will sagen wären wir noch
vorbereiten hatte ich einfach mal wir
haben jetzt in der packung noch diese
spritzte hier unter anderem gefunden
ich denke mal das wird dann später
dachte sein diese pommes zu machen
nudeln so oder so ich glaube das meiste
davon kennen wir eh nicht aber wollen
wir anfangen etwas zusammen zu mischen
wie gut man wie das aussieht das soll
brokkoli werden
gott wird vor allem was auch interessant
ist was kostet ohne packen weißt du es
nicht aus wenn ich also es kommt doch an
manchen 67 euro
mit populär
also brokkoli leute hat diese form also
diese würde sich außerdem zum shampoo so
ein bisschen
ok also leute da ist es jetzt und wir
rühren
jetzt wird schon superschnell bin ich
weiß nicht auch nicht zu wenig weiß aber
dass nicht überschrieben nach so raid
diesem amerikanischen ray player also
mäßig nennt aber es wird auf jeden fall
extrem becker also es ist wahrscheinlich
komplett ungesund aber lecker denn klein
[Musik]
so leute wir machen etwas allerletzte
päckchen und zwar diese nudeln also
erkennt man ja eindeutig dass das nur
gut sein sollen und tiefen wasser
brauchen wir dafür jetzt bestimmt auch
schon
na ja beide stunde dran oder sowas oder
20 minuten richtig richtig gespannt wie
das am ende schmecken wird aber ich
würde sagen wir machen das ziemlich gut
also könnte vielleicht was daraus werden
das wird definitiv zu leicht können
das liegt auch schon wieder nach einer
traube irgendwie besten unten in die
ecke wo hinkommt
das stellt man vor ihr habt so richtig
hunger und habe dieses pulver nur in der
wildnis bis zu drei stunden warten bis
es angerichtet ist also ein lästiger wir
versagen
die japaner haben ein hartes problem
dass man das macht also wenn ihr das mal
mit dem original vergleichen in der ecke
ist dieses grüne ding so soll es
wirklich aus und ich weiß nicht welche
mensch dass du hin bekommen sollen ich
habe die ganze zeit das zeug den fingern
wird schon probieren aber dann bisher
schon geschmeckt und dann wäre der
überraschungsmoment weg aber dass es so
klebrig ich denke mal das wird generell
süße snacks oder was auch immer
wie das ok das sieht jetzt richtig aus
wie auf dem bild oben und erste soll
dann scheint sein kann
so leute es ist vollbracht wir
mindestens mindestens eine halbe wenn
ich drei stunden insgesamt gebraucht
aber also leute ich probiere jetzt als
aller erstes mal dadurch am wenigsten
angst vor das ohr von dem panda also
hier habt ihr hier seht ihr das ohr und
ich lass das jetzt mal schön gruselig
baum macht mir das eigentlich mega
unerwartet hat irgendwie mit reis
gerechnet weil das ja das war so reißig
außerdem die arbeitssitzung einfach so
kennen die geschmacks bubblegum
geschmack lecker aber komisch das war zu
pulver hätte ich jetzt in original wäre
es bestimmt so mohn oder so das ist
jetzt einfach braucht
naja stimmt braucht mäßig als nächstes
mal die nudeln gehen kaum ab weil die
auch so klebrig und beliebig sind leute
es riecht schon wieder ziemlich ähnlich
probier's einfach mal war das
anscheinend so einem süßigkeiten dingen
keine ahnung von so was ich dachte dass
das verschafft es wird aber anscheinend
bisher schmeckt alles süße und auch
ziemlich gut muss ich sagen für die
konsistenz ist so unglaublich anders als
man sich vorstellt weise es bringt also
diese das pulver ist nur so leicht so
auf den zehen zu spüren als klebrig und
das ist megatrend einfach aber gut
eigentlich hier probiert und wir machen
es mir den schnelldurchlauf als nächstes
den tintenfisch
ok des lebens und riecht nach diesem cup
nach kaktus eis dieser rote teil der
rote teppich das problem des 21 wieder
lässt die konsistenz urkomisch aber
schmeckt auch ein bisschen eine leichte
erdbeer note grüner als nächste aus
schmeckt gut also derzeit auch wann
lohnt sich nicht würde ich sagen aber
dafür dass es so komisch aussehen
schmeckt es eine gelbe
aber ich freue mich ist man das in japan
als mahlzeit
methode nach zitronenschale aber nicht
mehr wie bisher waren direkt den reis am
besten was ich glaube das ist eine
bulette war weil das tiefe sucht
frittiert darauf aus es wird auch wieder
süß ich probiert also ich würde selbst
persönlich gerne wissen wie das mit
burger und sonst was schmeckt das war
jetzt eigentlich voll lecker also es
dauert eine ewigkeit und ist ziemlich
wenig aber es ist richtig lecker aber
auch mindestens so komisch wie es lecker
ist naja leute ihr könnt ihr gerne meine
kommentare schreiben wollt ihr dass das
noch mit der fast food box mache was ja
dann schreibt sie die kommentare und
ansonsten würde mich freuen wenn wir
einen daumen nach oben gibt und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder deuce